hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker -
I didn't notice this before but there's
an endless challenge mode which i think
is much like much like Oh 30 lives much
like the hundred Mario challenge except
this time not necessarily a hundred
Mario's I'm gonna start it on expert you
know
yeah expert I think I spent 15 lives on
those other expert levels I was doing
but we're gonna try this
Mario journey great let's go I don't
know why I'm nervous why should I be
nervous
oh boy I haven't played the 3d one you
know in a bit of a spell yeah so far so
good oh also goo okay not so bad stupid
oh god I'm so dumb I walked right into
that I'm so stupid I'm so stupid
that's my problem I'm just so dumb like
of course I was gonna happen why did
alright okay alright this is great this
is off to a great start this is such a
good stir I'm not the mechanic now it's
operate cuz I'll get done so happy so
happy my god oh goodness
gravy alright here we go Oh what are we
doing today what are we doing today mr.
snake oh that's new oh no wait wait wait
what are you doing what do you do okay
we're good we're good we're good
[Laughter]
oh my god I've never been more clenched
in oh please nothing
hence uma hi I think I felt
reverberations through time huh no no
I'm I ain't no quitter
no what have you heard about what who's
been talking behind my back I'm not a
quitter I don't I don't quit things I
destroy things in a fit of rage blind
pure rage if I hadn't been so stupid
about like you know that all right I
don't need another one but alright you
know it's all good now
we are in business now we are in biz
where's that wha no but not like this I
can make it oh god I can't make it Oh
[Music]
such a sad sack I'm sorry I didn't mean
to be this sad when I started this sweet
let's play where's that other one where
are you there you are you son of a [ __ ]
don't think that you can do such things
to me I don't wanna die I don't wanna
die
I just don't want to die this is the
problem you know I'm selfish in a way I
just don't want death could be fine I'm
up okay
made it nailed it got it love it what do
I do who knew the sack of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay bing-bong I'm a little bit salty
about that I don't know why that that
made me so enraged it's like I know it's
not out to get me but it sure feels like
it's out to get me right I'm not not
crazy in that department not ah you guys
sense what I'm what I'm what I'm selling
here you guys sense what I'm so this
feels like it might be my god I gotta
put my headphones back on it feels like
I might be in a bit of a spot of bother
as is uh you know as some hip spot a
spot of ah oh that grazed up right along
my butt cheeks there but owls go where
is that other flame I I know there's
another there's another flame coming by
somewhere I just don't know from whence
it would cut there she is there show I
so
wasn't there huh I'm not understanding
anything what's what's that what's the
mechanics here what's I'm not hard
percent sure what I'm supposed to do oh
no I don't see no fire no mo where's the
fire okay wait wait wait wait am I
supposed to know I'm not supposed to hit
that wait
no hitting that would be a terrible lie
dad would be a terrible idea if I hit
that you way are you doing what is the
big sonic looking donut do oh it's it's
a Boing it goes normal hey didn't know
this was my bus stop I'm fine it's just
a video game right that's the thing that
I've learned in my long and storied
history of doing a Let's Plays is at its
own not like what's that fancy maneuver
I did it sure it certainly was
impressive was it not certainly no yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
[Music]
all right I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm
gonna wait my turn
can I make this no I can't don't even
try why would I try now oh you are fun I
just hate that in front of me and then
you stroll it away perfectly timed it
fills the frame perfect freak up Oh God
never been never buck so dumb I just
wish it was possible for me not to be
this dumb all right here we go here we
go this is the one this is the one guys
this is the one it's the one I'm I'm
sigh just died I feel like the timing
was just an all right well that one was
my fault obviously we all know this but
we wouldn't say this because this is a
comforting place for for people that are
friendly and happy and I'm kidding you
sometimes I feel like there's three
sometimes I feel like there's two there
are different timers and such as the
like as its I'm this the wars you suck
so I'll see you stay here I say I I stay
right here I say right I need to move I
where were you when I needed you I don't
I don't get it do you get it I certainly
do not get it hey was such a fiery
passion I hate I burn my hatred burns it
burns my hatred burns hotter than the
lava coming up to scorched my butt
cheeks
I just hate with all the vim and vigor
in my life stay out of my danger zone
sad
Yuson [ __ ] we're waiting for my danger
zone who's son of a [ __ ] I know I know
you I know the pain you mean to cause me
oh I've gotta fart yes I can't you can
make it I thought you could make it
I suspected it to be thus look at me
a gosh-darn hero what where are they
where are they I don't trust this at all
oh there you are
there you are you son of a [ __ ] I'm
just gonna go for it I made it nailed it
I'm gonna go for this and I made that
and I'm just gonna wait up here hey time
is my [ __ ]
I'm not times [ __ ] I I define my oh I
forgot about you oh [ __ ] you're gonna
bounce Oh duck I got it there you are my
friend I would never badmouth you I
don't know why but all the flames seem
to be you know just kind of gone go know
why but they're kind of just not here
you think I need your charity you think
I need your your old boy this is gonna
take some doing
oh no doing for me today oh no do me no
do me oh I was there
I was there I had everything I had my
youth my looks I know your face palming
at me I'm aware that I goofy I'm aware
not making this I made that I'm making
all of this it's all happening
you know what I don't even need your
charity yeah okay maybe maybe I need
some charity here oh wait this was a
mistake
oh no it's not it's a perfect exactly
what I wanted
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes this is
the day that I shall be known as the
Conqueror I am just the best look at me
powerful strong and some have it all
what more could I ask for nothing I say
nothing I've got it all now watch as I
complete my magnum opus you need to get
out of there little friend you're you
know what fire can't burn the dragon oh
[Music]
excuse me
hey excuse me oh excuse him wait hang on
wait no hang on wait my ride yeah oh but
no who needs ride when you've got this I
love me why is it still going up it's
the question I've I have what's up here
I'm gonna go let me up there get me in
there
get me in there I'm a baby let me hit
there
okay okay all right what are we doing
here what are we doing what are we doing
what are we doing you let me in there oh
yeah you are oh yes yes yes yes
why am I not done why why am I not done
why am I not done why am I not done is
the question I have
oh hi hello okay am I ooh Oh juice juice
juice all right I'm done and Marga buyer
number I almost beat the record I almost
beat the Rec I really AM number two guys
I did I made it alright let's keep going
I'm having a great time guys this is off
awesome almost vomited alright let's
keep it rolling let the good times roll
yeah alright cool love this oh yeah now
that's what I'm talking about oh yeah
this feels good hey I'm gonna stomp you
and stomp you let's get out here I feels
good oh yeah you know that's how I roll
always prepared for anything really wait
what okay hey I'll take it you know what
I'll take that I feel pretty good about
that that's pretty good look at me guys
look at me look at me look at me here we
go oh whoops I didn't I'm making this
nope I don't know why I decided to
sprint like that okay oh no we're not
not so quick not so oh yeah let me on
you what are those what are those I
forgot I'm not able to wall jump off for
God it's not 3d Mary oh I like when it
says turn back I'm thinking that maybe
there might be some
oh well you know that's that's why we
have mushes turn why is this keep saying
it wants me to turn back I don't I don't
understand what what what what what what
no wait wait what wait all right here we
go
I think those were like supposed to be a
clue as to where I was supposed to go oh
god I forget if it's slightly over I
don't know it's like right about here I
can't turn back I am committed all right
so it's slightly one more over here
there right there right here right here
this is the one this is the one yeah
yeah oh yeah I think those those yeah
those jump-scares are furred I'm
definitely in your ass what do we do now
oh don't don't even tell me our here we
go again
all right what am I waiting for
Oh wiggler a wiggler oh okay hey Monty I
didn't know if I needed to do that but I
do no no no okay all right we're good
it's great but it's beetle well no
cannonball Oh am I supposed to fall
again oh god oh god no oh god here we go
oh no I don't know I thought if I ran
over you you wouldn't kill me but I did
anyway I couldn't run out of lives here
hey that's enough for me guys I'm all
out of time catch you in the next one I
needed that I think I watch this yeah
yeah you see this nailed it
you suck so hard I need that mush to get
through there this is it guys this is it
this is the moment guys shut up stop
talking stop typing your comment this is
it this is the moment
[Music]
I'm just a little
that's my let's play of expert endless
mode I think I did okay I think I did
all right a high score of two that put
me in like 30 but thank you everybody so
much for watching hope you enjoyed this
if you want more Mario maker let me know
down in the comments below thanks
everybody for watching be sure to check
out my other Mario maker stuff and stay
tuned for even more amazing Mario maker
stop ring that Bell I'll see you guys
but yeah thanks and as always I see you
next one
[Music]